[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round one of the
summer classic here in st. Louis the
masters division was highlighted by for
decisive games in favor of grandmasters
Dhirubhai Lee seve on a Kobe on and king
of the Spring Classic Jeffrey Jean the
17 year old capitalized on a
miscalculation by Kazakh champ Juma
bhaiyya
for the point two full points were
awarded in Group B as Grandmaster a
lemur on day one a piece early making
quick work of grandmaster bellows in the
final game to conclude grandmaster
dragoon finished a bishop up in a rook
and pawn end game against international
masters saduak a soba round two coverage
starts now with 35 grand on the line 20
international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as us chess champs
comm presents the first ever summer
chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the st. Louis
chess club studio and the 2018 summer
chess classic I mean women grandmaster
Catriona Tova and I am here with
international master Eric Rosen that's
right and we have a very strong fueled
taking place right now we have two very
strong groups of very masters and we
don't see this type of tournament every
day where it's it's a round-robin format
with so many of the GM's this is usually
the type of tournament which takes place
among super grandmasters but it's going
to be some very exciting chess to look
forward to and today we have the second
round of the summer chess classic but
let's look what happened yesterday for
the yesterday results of Group A results
one yeah we have a ton of decisive
results in Group A for decisive games
with Sam seven of the sea star Bayley
version of Kobe and Jeffrey's on all
getting off to a very nice start with
winning their first-round games and the
group standings group standings for
around round two or going into round two
we see a very divided divided group here
with a lot of players getting off to a
slow start
we have four players with zero points
Daniel Friedman Peter Prohaska
Arunachala bio and Alexander ninjas
I'm sure looking to hopefully come back
strong in round two absolutely and let's
look at the yesterday's results of Group
B there we had only two decisive rounds
were Camille Dragoon one against
Daenerys aduba cassava and vladimir
bellows one against lost against JJ
Allen Morandi the other games were a
draw so when we go to the second round
we see the result that only cannon
dragon and Ally Miranda are leading the
pack that's right and we should keep in
mind that morandi one based off very
careless blunder by Bella so maybe it
was some first round rust that her first
round nervousness that Bellas felt butts
times when you when you get in the
rhythm of the tournament then there will
be less Lundy's going forward
absolutely so let just ask for the
graphics for standings for Group B
that's right and we should note to the
viewers that you can see all the
pairings standings and games on us chef
champs calm in Group B we have two
leaders Camille dragon and jayjay a
lemur Andy leading the pack still a lot
of chess to be played absolutely so the
tournament format we have 210 player
round robins with time control 90
minutes 440 moves plus 30 minutes for
the reminder remainder of their game and
with 30 second increment from move one
that's right and we should also keep in
mind there's a 30 move no draw rule
which means players cannot accept a draw
up a form of 30 this should lead to a
lot of fighting and lot of exciting
chests absolutely so let's look at the
schedule for this tournament that's
right we have games starting at 1 p.m.
central time every day until the last
day where the round starts too early 2
hours earlier at 11 a.m. and if there is
a tie in either group there will be a
playoff on Wednesday the 23rd at 5 p.m.
I know we would be looking forward to
that absolutely we are always excited
about the playoffs so let's see what's
happening today round 2 for group a
right we have the round 2 pairings some
exciting matchups with Benjamin Bach
versus Renata mabye of revision of
Cobian against Geoffrey Zhang Massif
Tara Bailey against Alexander in Dutch
Peter / Houska against Daniel Friedman
and euro jariabek against Sam subunit
the key matches the key matchup is
absolutely clear
it's very shikko beyond against Geoffrey
Zhang two very strong Americans that's
right and they're both fresh off the US
Championship we should keep in mind they
actually played in the US Championship
with the same colors they have today and
I'm sure it's gonna be a hard fought
game the game is actually already
underway and we should go ahead and take
a look we see Geoffrey they're sitting
corrosion perhaps walking around maybe
getting something to eat
oh no there he is walking back to the
board and we have a position which was
pretty sharp earlier but it seems like
the dust has settled and it looks like
the the position might be simplifying
relatively quickly to a draw I mean I
mean the rooks are about to get traded
its bishops of the same color material
is equal so I don't think we'll need to
spend too much time analyzing this game
yes maybe we will get back to this game
but let's see what is the run to for
group B pairings that's right and in
Group B for round two we have Daenerys
ah do Kesava against JJ Olli Morandi
andrey zhuk open against Vladimir Ballas
Alejandra Ramirez against Robert akka
sorry and Sergey Mott Senko against Josh
Vidal and Camille dragon against Tata of
Abraham Ian and the key matchup is
Camille dragon against attack abraham
Ian we have the world champion under 16
European champion under 16 against the
Olympic US Olympic team member at F
Abraham Ian who was actually very close
once to win the US Women's Championship
that's right and we should keep in mind
that Camille dragon is a top-rated
player in Group B and Tata is the lowest
rated player so there's a pretty big
rating differential in this match given
that Camille dragon it's over 25 50 feet
a I believe Tata vis around 23 50 feet a
so we'll have to see how that game is
progressing so let's see I'm of course
rooting for Tutera who is my US team
member so let's see how is she doing
that's right we can see both players
very intently focused on the board
currently the position looks very very
crazy I mean I have to say I don't like
blocks position given just whites very
harmonious setup Queen on d4 Knight on
e3 rooks mm F file and and Black's
overextended pawn on e4 it seems like
more of a weakness than it is a strength
yes it looks more comfortable for a
white on the other hand if we exchange
the nice we have same color bishops
we may try it some rooks I mean you also
need some material to win a game so well
let's see what are the prizes that the
players are fighting for that's right
there's a lot of money up for grabs
there's a very generous 22 $22,000 with
a $6,000 first-place prize that's a lot
of money for nine days of chess
I think players are very happy to be
competing for its money and also to be
competing in such a nice place as its
aunt Louise that's right and we have
also a very generous prize fund for
Group B with $14,000 up for grabs $4,000
$4,000 for first place and there's a lot
of college students playing in this
event so I'm sure some of these prizes
could fund a pretty nice summer vacation
I agree and I think college students are
very relaxed now after finals and that
makes me think about the game
Yara's Arabic is just playing I mean her
his opening what do you think about that
Eric I mean yeah for those of you who
are just joining us we have a we had a
very strange first few moves in the yard
Arabic game against Samuel 7 with a
three on move one when was the last time
you've seen an opening like this
Katarina I mean you can expect anything
from me arrow or force from similar
players but I don't remember seeing
anything like that yeah I mean yeah it's
very bizarre the the logic behind this
is yaro maybe wanted to play a black
opening in this game and it's just maybe
Wake making a waiting move with a three
and what happened in the game after E 5
URL played maybe another very strange
move C 3 but actually what transpired is
we had a reverse caro-kann after d5 and
d4 and I mean if you look at the
position after we moved to this this
might just be a novel a novel position
actually now I remember my teammate when
I used to play for the Czech team she
used the same variation out in the at
the European team championship against
Zhukova it was very interesting because
she wanted just to get Cara Khan with
with white and this is the best way
actually to do that because a 3 may be
valuable move in in CARICOM that's the
big question is a 3 actually helping
white in any way if we go for it and see
what happened in the game I mean it
seems like the pawn is just sitting
there doing nothing and White's white
just lost a tempo for no reason and
opening I really like the way Sam
proceeded in this position he provoked
white to play g3 and then he wasted no
time going for a pretty menacing attack
with pawn to h5 looking to not only open
up the file for the rook but also try
and open up the diagonal for the Queen
Bishop battery so if we look how the
game progressed after c4h for the H file
did open up and eventually we got into a
very sharp position with opposites like
castling and you know positions like
this both players want to attack on the
side where their opponents King is yes
and I was preparing this variation
actually for the white color during us
championship so this is very similar to
the main line that we can get just we
are we have different different colors
so I think Yara maybe even in in his
prep understanding what is happening in
this game that's right and I really like
the sequence of moves that Sam played
with c5 followed by Bishop c6 where
there is long term ideas of exploiting
the diagonal and coordinating both the
bishop and the rook and maybe some
potential checkmate ideas on this h1
square and it's usually not a good sign
when the Queen is aligned with the
bishop and of course white has to be
very careful here few more moves have
been played after Bishop g5 Bishop e7
Bishop d2 Knight f6 unleashing the
bishop creating the pin on the knight
Bishop c3 and rook h6 brings us to the
current position where it seems like
White has a lot of issues to deal with
absolutely and someone yesterday very
nice game so he may be on fire to win
another one today that's right it seems
like he's he's going all out for the win
with the black pieces yes I mean why not
when you're when your opponent plays a
three I move one so we can we can
imagine that blacks attack is only going
to get stronger with with rook h8 on the
horizon and I I would feel very
uncomfortable for whites
not to mention that there's potential
ideas with c4 maybe disturbing the
bishop and I mean he fours a very big
target and the knight currently can't
move because it's pinned yes but let's
look maybe at a Durham and B there is an
interesting position that Sergei matte
Senko has again Josh Ford oh that's
right and and I think the position is
especially interesting for Josh Trudel
who I always spawn up now we can see
that it was actually a very positional
middlegame from a Catalan opening which
now has transpired into a very seemingly
strategic endgame where black is up upon
but can you really admire this structure
from black especially this bishop on
eight I don't admire it but I always
admire when I am material up that's
right I mean would you prefer the extra
pawn or just the clearly superior rook
on a seven and Bishop on g2 I think the
issue is that why is gonna play rook c7
and then get the pawn back anyway but
then we will end up with some Josh
rookin game that's possible sometimes
positions like this if black can maybe
give back upon and activate the the
bishop activate the rook and that the
position can be drawn relatively quickly
but I would imagine that Sergei Motte
Cinco is the one playing for a win in
this game really I'm not sure because if
if you don't play rook c7 now and I play
just Bishop e7 I can then move with the
King defend the pawn forever yeah I see
so I guess it's a question of whether
white can kind of make use of the
temporary advantage when you have more
active pieces you want you want to be
quick with your play you don't want to
resort to slower plans and we can see
yeah Black has a plan that perhaps
bringing the King in and I I can imagine
what c7 is a candidate move that Sergei
is is considering and it's it seems to
be winning back the pawn no matter what
I mean rook b6 would not be playable
because of rook c8 check winning the
bishop and meanwhile I mean at any time
I can just take the pawn and get a
slightly better working game and we have
a comment from YouTube asking why are we
not showing evaluation we are not using
any engines during this analysis so
that's why there is no evaluation we
really want to explain the game
understand what's HAP what is happening
in the position so we feel that if we
have the computer they are telling us
the evaluation we would lose the really
nature of understanding the position and
that's very true and we don't have a
Maurice Ashley we can send to for all
the engine analysis but having said that
we do want to make it instructive for
the viewers so we will be keeping an eye
on the youtube chats and if you have any
questions comments feedback let us know
and we'll try and make it in
gauging for the viewers so with that
let's move on to some other interesting
games another game that popped or that
caught my eye in Group B is the battle
between alejandro ramirez and robert
raucous Orion which featured a very
unusual opening and I actually want to
go back and see how Alejandro played in
this opening and maybe ask you if you've
seen anything like this before
we had a symmetrical English which seems
pretty standard until Alejandra went for
a very creative and unusual night
maneuver 91 93 and 94 you don't see this
every day I don't but we have to keep in
mind that Alejandro he is the coach of
snow team so they may have many
preparations with the table GM's here
that's very true I mean I know Alejandro
specifically spends a lot of time with
opening preparation and if I'm not
mistaken he has some specialized
computer built for chess built for
analyzing openings and delving deep into
opening theory but nights on D 3 and E 4
in the center ponds the Knights are
attacking sefa tonight can you know take
the bishop when it wants to
that's very true the Knights exert a lot
of pressure on black setup and that's
probably what Alejandro is going for
rather than controlling the center with
a pawns he's controlling the center with
the minor pieces let's zoom forward
because the position got even spicier
after after development was completed
Alejandra went for the f4 thrust trying
to deep destabilize box box central pawn
on e5 and forcing the trade which which
maybe created some tactical
possibilities against the Kings side
with a nice open diagonal for the bishop
I can very easily envision ideas like
King H one rook g1 and there's
definitely some attacking potential for
whites so if we go forward even further
f5 was played I have to say I'm very
impressed with Alejandra so far I think
he's he's playing very creative chess
this does remind me kind of the style of
Vladimir Kramnik who is known for
playing like these ready English
positions with the CC and Cato and
kramnik maybe no
a more positional player but I've seen
many chronic games where he has a sort
of setup with Bishop b2 that pong lunges
forward and I mean plaque seems to be
under major pressure especially when we
see the bishop on B - I like how bishops
can be kind of backstage in background
but be so powerful we saw it yesterday
in the game of now remind me who was
that person I think there are a good
number of there was a bishop on b7 that
was very powerful now we have Bishop on
b2 together with the knight on d3 this
cooperation is just great for y so I do
think that black may face some troubles
here it's true and Alejandra played
somewhat of a surprising move here given
that he is attacking he actually played
Queen h5 going for a queen trade which
is a bit a bit suspicious but maybe he's
trying to continue the attack
even without Queens on the board if we
imagine some something predicted line
like Queen take age 590 h5 we can see
that there's a very juicy target on g6
with rook g4 on the horizon still
looming ideas of King h1z1 and the sort
of position says that you don't always
need a queen to attack your opponent's
king yes but go all the way to the
current position I'm a little worried
about what's happening here yeah a few
more moose have been played actually
black did not capture on each five black
captured on g3 what is it there may be a
tactical trick with 95 so white is what
just happened there this should take g3
yes
oh the knight was on g3 okay I thought I
thought there was a pawn in g3 so the
the bishop traded for the nine and g3
Queens got traded on h6 and now Knight
a5 with the threat of Bishop if they
should be 5 and pinning the knight and
the rook yeah it's a it looks like a
very complex battle like black wants to
exploit maybe the the awkwardness of
whites pieces but it's a question of
whether white can maybe exploit blacks
weaken Kings side especially these
double H pawns the bishops still
beautifully placed on on me too any
predictions well white my foot here
I think my prediction is that white will
move something like rubgy for and after
we should be 5 just to sacrifice the
exchange to go maybe neither 4 and try
to utilize the bishop on b2 with some
tricks with Knight h5 9 f6 there is some
future in that position we have to think
about the night on g5 that is so useless
it cannot go anywhere yeah I think it's
just a matter of making it actually work
if we imagine like Bishop say Gough one
King take f1 black might get some
counter play with rook take d2 and
positions like this you really want to
seize initiative and when you're the one
attacking you don't want to give the
initiative to your opponent so white
does have to be careful with maybe
letting black get to me
too many strong threats and we have a
result in Group B where Daenerys adora
Kesava drew against JJ Ali morandi I
will say that I don't think your of us
were taking a look at that game earlier
we see what seems to be a very equal
position coming from a Catalan opening
and we saw this yesterday in one of the
games where like in these Catalan
positions the middle game can be very
sharp but when things get traded when
the the center kind of liquidates its
left with very symmetrical pawn
structure and that's what we see here I
don't think we need to spend too much
time delving into this game but I'm
interested in the game to copy Andre and
Belle's Vladimir they are both teammates
at the utrgv University so let's see how
they are playing against each other
because they must know each other very
well that's right and I actually want to
show the opening in that game because it
was it was what you see in scholastic
tournaments a very symmetrical King's
pawn opening with really not too much
impressive opening preparation I mean
III recently was at the the k-6
elementary Nationals in Nashville over
2000 young players and I saw positions
like this and maybe I don't want to say
every other game but a good portion of
the games so I think because they know
each other so well because they're from
the same team they might be just going
for a Josh line just to save energy for
the rest of the tournaments it's
possible on the other hand I know Andre
stick often he was actually I was at the
University when he was there as well and
he's a fighting player he wants to fight
when he has black when he has white
pieces so he might just start with
something not risky and then see if he
can push for more that's very true
let's go back to the Sam 7 game because
because a few moves have been played and
I mean the position is looking I don't
say gruesome for a white but but a bit
problematic for white given that black
has pretty much optimized the rooks
bishops still on c6 and it's Jerry books
move he's thinking and I mean what to do
for whites that's a very good question
and yarrow has only 22 minutes to figure
it out that's right maybe the better
question is what is the threat for black
sometimes in this position when you're
defending you don't necessarily want to
think about what you want to do you want
to think about what your coin wants to
do and how you either prevent it or
counter-attack in this case after the
move Bishop take f6 black might be
considering just simply improving the
bishop with Bishop d4 and further
optimizing the pieces so I think the
question for a white is how do you deal
with the pin against the night and I
mean how how can you maybe improve the
position and not let black optimize even
further
do you see any moves that that white
might be considering here I just want to
go back for a second to what you said so
when we think about blacks threat if I
was black and I had three moves in a row
I could do I would just play Bishop
before rook h3 and Bishop takes d4 and
I'm taking rook to e3 and the position
is one is very simple to take but it may
be difficult for a white to defense a
defend against it because the h-file is
an issue and now you have to think okay
what am I gonna do here that's true and
a move has been played yaro played rook
takes e5 grabbing the undefended pawn
but I'm very curious if Bishop d4 can't
be played anyway and we can see there's
a lot of like tactical targets that
white has to be concerned about with the
rook
kind of exposed on c5 of course the King
on g1 the knight and queen aligned with
the bishop so I'd be very curious if
some move like Bishop d4 can still be
played with your idea of rook h3 and
going after the g3 targets yes and I
don't want to be too crazy but even
Bishop d4 and Bishop takes f2 can be an
interesting line because whenever the
Queen captures on f2 we have Rho Chi
Chuan
whenever Knight captures the Queen on f3
is hanging and so the king usually has
to have to has to capture on f2 but in a
rook h2 and there the bishop on c6 is
really strong the rooks can be strong
that's why I was why that would be
worried about this position for sure
yeah just to illustrate the move like
rook takes e4 bishop take f2 it feels
we're taking upon this defended that
appears to be defended by three things
but what you mentioned a move like
Queen's egg f2 runs into a rook H 1
while the knight can't take because it
spins and if the king takes maybe this
isn't the most accurate line that that
can play right away but ideas like rook
h2 or Queen b6 sometimes it's all about
looking for ways to grab the initiative
and at this high high elite level with
GM's they're looking for forcing lines
they're looking for for variations that
they can predict and lines that that are
forcing that their opponent has to go
into and I wouldn't be surprised if if
Sam will be calculating the forcing
moves in this position now we should
note he is running low on time he is
below 10 minutes with still if we get to
the current position after rook takes e5
he has about 15 moves to make until time
control which is actually not a lot of
time that's maybe a minute per move on
average so maybe a position like this
yes to rely on intuition yes it's a it's
a very tactical position but when you
are at low on time it's difficult you
have to be precise you don't want to
just capture something sacrifice and
hope for good you really have to
calculate so of course he's not in such
a great position with
time but to slow down a little bit I
would like to see the position of
verrico bein against Jeffrey Xiang the
key matchup because we have an end game
there where the black pawn may be
actually a weak and I think var can be
having some tiny advantage yes move pawn
to e4 to e3 maybe a bit unexpected and
the king is actually doing a very good
job at blockading the pawn putting
constant pressure on the pawn and the
king can't easily be removed from E to
so I'm a bit curious about the the
reasoning behind pawn to e3 I wonder if
there's some some liquidation that's
about to take place I mean there's a lot
of tension not only between the bishops
but but also between the rooks so what I
think about move 3 if you don't make III
then I just take the bishop and push
looking further King III and then you
have still the same issue you are
worrying with blockade and the pawn on
e4 is weak that's true I wonder if III
was kind of a desperado move where
Geoffrey realizes that the pawn is going
to be lost in law of lines and he's
trying to to make the most that he can
of the pawn this is kind of a kamikaze
move going for perhaps a positional
sacrifice where even if if the pawn is
taken then the e-file can open up with
perhaps encountered play for the rook on
he Yeats so another game that is
catching my attention that I think we
should go back to is a game between
alejandro ramirez and who is he playing
he's playing Robert Haga saurian which
we were taking a look at earlier and he
played the move Knight f4 which we were
analyzing some ideas like this where
black will block could win the exchange
but white appears to be getting a lot of
counter play and we mentioned earlier
that the knight could potentially go to
h5 and come in to f6
but there's another path for the night
to to come into d5 with the mate threat
of 97 and this is a classic classic
mating idea just to demonstrate for for
the viewers
let's imagine black ticks on c4 actually
night 95 right away would not be not be
good because of night take b2 so after
pawn takes e5 maybe this isn't the best
example line but if black plays some
waiting moves it's possible to so I have
to deal with this threat at some point
with 97 yeah let's just look at the
bishop the bishop on b2 the bishop on g2
i mean they are just dominating the
board like if you think about these
bishops being maybe better than than the
rook right now the question for blacks
should you take the rook on c4 or should
you maybe focus on on defending what
would what would be your first instincts
what I like of not while not taking the
rook is most like a bishop c6 at least
trait one of the bishops but I don't
know if we are in time to do that
because 95 is a serious threat with
Knight f6 coming up that's right and I
should point out that they're only
unmoved 23 and Robert has less than 10
minutes on the clock and this does not
appear to be a fun position for black to
play especially with the time dwindling
down and I mean it just seems so much
more fun for white and sometimes when
you reach the time pressure situation
you want to be the one with initiative
you want to be the one making the
threats put your opponent under pressure
because that's usually what will provoke
lunders I think this is a very difficult
situation for black and he has seven
minutes to figure out what you do here
that's really to the pond so he made a
move Bishop takes a five is what
happened on the board mm-hmm grabbing
the pawn but when pawns are taken files
open up and we can see the rook is
aligned with the undefended Bishop on a5
as 95 not just attacking two things
with the threat of 97 and wrote a got
five what would black do in this
position after 95 I can maybe just
capture rook takes d5 mmm and then
capture and see for sure but if I go
Knight h5 and I don't allow this capture
so you're suggesting like h5 here
because uh the knight is clearly more
powerful than the rook right yes that's
what I think
and then h5 hits a bishop turns a very
nasty 906 check I'm sure Alejandro is is
calculating options sometimes when you
when you have the momentum going going
for you in a game and you're the one
attacking you want to consider multiple
ways to progress and you always want to
strive to play the best move so if you
see a move like 95 and it looks good
you don't want to just play it
immediately you always want to strive to
play the best move in the position and
I'm sure Alejandro is calculating some
of the forcing lines trying to make the
best decision possible
so before we see what Howard is
happening in the game let's look at
Peter Prohaska against Daniel Friedman
right and that's a new game that I don't
believe we've looked at so far seems
like a somewhat strategic minor piece
endgame I think yesterday the theme was
opposite to coloured bishop and bishops
and today we have same colored bishops
that's right there's been at least a few
games today with with bishops of the
same color now we should note in this
position that's equal material both
sides have four pawns LightSquared
bishop and the knight normally a bishops
bishop endings of the same color you
want your pawns on opposite color of the
bishop and if we know this in this
position all of whites pawns placed on
dark squares which probably benefits
white given that there's LightSquared
bishops on the board and if we should
point out that the box pawn in e6 and
pawn and I 5 they're fixed on light
squares and this could be perhaps a
slight long-term positional weakness for
black and I wouldn't be surprised if
white tries to perhaps play for the win
not only with these weak pawns but also
with the outside past past a pawn I
think the passport that's the key role
of this of this position the passport
will have
a really important part where it will be
distracting the black pieces while white
can attack the other pawns on in the
center and under King sight that's very
true and I should just give some kind of
basic lesson about pawns because usually
at the beginning of the game or middle
Game Center pawns are more valuable but
in the endgame
if you have a outside pass pawn that can
be that can be extremely valuable
because it can act as a decoy and it
could perhaps decoy blocks pieces into
moving towards the Queen side while
white can try and take advantage of the
positional weaknesses on the Kings side
so I'm sure Peter is as a one looking to
play for a win here we have a result of
a game Vasily did our ballet won another
game against ended Alexander this time
Wow and this is a game that we have not
paid attention to let's see how how he
won this this brings Wasif two to two
wins in a row perfect start for him and
we talked to him yesterday and he he
said he's in the midst of completing
finals in the final paper to to complete
I believe today and a final exam and he
can't get off to a better start than
this yeah and unfortunately not a very
good start for Alexandra indeed who lost
the first round against Jericho Beyond
and now lost another round against the
silver barley that's right let's take a
look at how the position transpired but
see if actually had a very classic
imbalance where it's Queen and Night vs
Queen and Bishop and the general rule is
Queen and Knight can coordinate so much
better than Queen and Bishop because the
the queen a knight moved differently so
they don't overlap each other in certain
situations and they can target any
square on the board while the Bishop is
limited just to just so the color square
that that it's on so already at this
point it seems like Wasif had had a very
pleasant position knight on d4 very
nicely centralized and blacks pawns you
notice they're fixed on dark squares
which are perhaps long-term targets for
for the white pieces and look at the
bishop on these
I mean the bishop has no future you
cannot go anywhere that's very sad
such a sad Bischoff yeah with I mean the
pawns are on light squares in the center
and like the bishop is even restricted
by whites pawns on the Queen side so
while the pawns restricting this very
sad Bishop in the position and the Seif
has seemed to have a few ways of winning
this position going for the King side
attack but also maybe going for the
positional weaknesses on the Queen side
and it seems very straightforward from
here where before can't be defended and
he just it was just a matter of
technique really Knight c2 and the pawns
just fall and I take a three and then
black just resigns given that Knight c4
is coming and the passed pawns will
prove decisive yeah so this was very
interesting game were safe with another
win he's up to a very good start
so let's look now at the game Yara's
Arabic against Sam Sabian because there
was so much tactics happening so much to
calculate and now there is an endgame
what happened this looks like a
completely new position I mean we were
having so much fun earlier debating or
discussing the potential future of the
attack for Sam and now we have a very
dry obstacle our Bishop ending I
wouldn't be surprised if the game ends
in a draw very soon we should at least
go back and see how this how this
happened as many moves have been played
they're already approaching move 40 I
can see that rook h1 was played which is
maybe the first first step in
simplifying the position Queen take h1
and we had this material imbalance with
two rooks for whites and the Queen for
black and things just got traded very
quickly I can see that maybe this was
all calculated out and maybe Sam saw
nothing more than just to go for the
slide and and and be safe and just take
a draw I mean we have to remember that
he had only eight minutes so it's really
not enough time to calculate crazy
variations but I do feel the position
had potential for more than
be straight yeah sometimes especially
early on in the tournament you don't
want to take too many risks especially
with time ticking down it's clear what
happened that he saw a bell outline
where he's he's okay taking a draw he
had a very nice one yesterday and going
into round three with with one and a
half father to that's that's not a bad
sorry for him yes they are still playing
but our predictions are that it's gonna
be draw soon so let's move on to Jeffrey
shank and Verico be on it's right and we
have some developments in that game too
sticking with the theme of Bishops of
the same color we can apply the rule
that we saw in the previous position
look at all of blacks pawns and look at
all of whites pawns all of whites pawns
on light squares all of box pawns on
dark squares who does this benefit
katarina see I think this clearly
benefits white that would be my guess
yeah of course white because the pawn
not only the pawns are on the dark side
but also I think it's very important to
see the pawn on d5 which can just run to
a queen and it can be a huge issue for
black to be always worrying for release
pawn for its potential like doesn't have
a chance to create a passed pawn because
a6 b5 I mean that doesn't have any
future so not only I can be capturing
the pawns on dark dark squares but the D
pawn that's a real problem so I think
Jeffrey will have to figure out how to
how to defend this position yeah I will
say that Akopian excels in these
positions where he has just a small
advantage going into the endgame and
I've only played them once in tournament
chess but he very methodically outplayed
me from what seemed to be an equal
position but he's very good at building
up small advantages he has an amazing
endgame technique and we can see here
there's there's many Trump's for him in
the position given the defended past
pawn on d5 and also given just box pawns
are fixed on dark squares h4 is a
long-term weakness in a7 is long term
weakness so I wouldn't be surprised if
he can manage to growing this out I
think the interesting thing that we can
notice here that maybe white can't even
trade rooks
and win this position because I can win
the H for pawn when the rooks are off
and the D pawn will be running that's
true I mean black probably wants to keep
rooks on the board and if black wants to
trade anything it's the dark squared
bishop scuzz white star squared bishop
has a lot more potential to cause damage
to blacks position it is a question
though I don't think white can initiate
a rook trade any time soon but maybe
maybe it's just a matter of activating
the rook perhaps the Kobe and is
considering a move like rook f6 try and
get into the black territory maybe
invade via h6 or even c6 and I can
imagine that that white can be making
pretty clear progress here not to
mention there's some future plan at 85
trying to destabilize this pawn chain on
the Queen side yes so let let's move on
to another game I think there is a very
interesting position in the game to
copying and Ray and bellows ready meal
there's this Knight h6 that looks so
dangerous for black students for some
reason I'm having a hard time finding
bead from the B okay let's try and find
that game 86
I mean the King is weak there can be
some mating threats if you immediately
capture cheap on take h6 there is rook
f7 checkmate
so and if you take with King there is
Luke h3 coming up you have to maybe play
something like Knight h4 just to
demonstrate those lines of course pawn
can't take because of rook rook f7 mates
and you said after King take rook h3 no
you have to play Knight h4 and I need
sure actually it cannot be played
because they just wrote a cage for so
King Oh King g5 is not legal the knight
can't be taken so that but now what do
you want to do you probably have to move
away the Queen and there's Queen g8 fork
I'm attacking the King I'm attacking the
rook on d6 it's right and we dismiss
this game earlier thinking it was gonna
be a very boring draw given the symmetry
in the opening given that these players
are teammates but it looks like stuck
open maybe
maybe found some way to play for an
advantage but remember I told you I just
thought that he's playing something very
easy no risks to result game and just
hope for a push and it looks like he
found something no we have a result do
we have another result in group a it's
an Savion euros era book back in did and
in a draw
officer Clark Bishop ending really
nothing to play for free either side I
don't think we have to stick with that
game should we stick with this game I
mean can we can we safely conclude that
black is in massive trouble here and
this might even be close to resign well
given that if in light can't be taken
the night is going to come to at five as
as yasser sarah juan likes to say knife
at five amazing attacking peace followed
by a idea like rock h3 and king take
eight six happened
so what black will try after rook h3
probably captured a look with a queen
and that would happen as well so black
will try to build a fortress to to draw
a game I mean 19 rooks there can be very
good defenders but I can't imagine black
dogs creating a fortress in these
position
Magnus Carlsen has this this well-known
quote I don't believe in fortresses and
a position like this I mean one has it
White has a pawn and a queen for a rook
and Knight so unfortunately I think that
was the only try that black has
otherwise to resign and we have to
remember that these players they really
want to fight they want to you know play
their best and see if they can push up
for a couple more moves and see that
maybe opponents can make a mistake as
well that is true but I have to put
heavy money on on Andre for for
converting this game so any other games
to take a look at there there are a
number of Java of developments happening
in in time trouble what about the key
matchup coming the dragwon and tactical
Brahimi on some attack and now we see
this Camilla is a pawn up and guess what
another position of Bishops of the same
color which I don't think we've we've
looked at since the
in liquidated if we go back to see how
everything got raided
rooks traded on that file twice for that
matter and white is upon up with
potential outside past pawn and that's
exactly what happened but what we see
here compared to the other game is that
the darks were the pawns for black are
on dark squares and the bishop cannot
attack them so it's not that easy for
camel to actually do something with his
bishop other than supporter past pawn
where a staff can try to attack the the
pawns in the white camp
if the bishop tries to go away from the
diagonal that's true and I don't believe
that black will have an easy time
attacking this it's pretty immaculate
pawn shame the only way to try and
attack the pawn chain is to get the
bishop to be one but that's where it's
currently off-limits and meanwhile Maeby
meanwhile a pawn break like a four could
be considered but that can run into be
four so I guess it's a question of it
really it's a question of how is White's
making progress in in this position I
think there can be big chances of black
just holding this position because if
white tries to put the bishop on the d1
h5 diagonal then I can go
Bishop c2b should be one and two some
annoying stuff there it's actually true
like know what we just said that Magnus
Carlsen doesn't believe in fortresses
but the king is just going to stay where
it is on f6 the bishop will stay on d1
controlling these squares so black
actually has a wall controlled by the
king and the bishop and it's not easy
for whites to break through the wall as
you mentioned if the bishop tries to
maneuver to this diagonal it allows box
and counter play on the Queen side so
I'd be very curious to see how Camille
attempts to win this game
yes but what about other games let's see
let's see Alejandra Ramirez against
Robert Alcazar Ian yeah we saw that
physician had a lot of fire earlier and
it seems to be a theme for today that
physicians that are very sharp in the
middle game are transpiring into various
strategic end games we can see that
Alejandra did not fully lose the
exchange or if he did lose exchange he
won it back he did play this 95 move
threatening the mate on on e7 and I
guess they went into a line that we were
looking at rook take t5 Bishop take t5
Knight takes e4 b takes e4 and if we go
forward to the current position anything
to make of this somewhat imbalanced yes
and it is the rook on efile that's a
great troop with some threats rookie to
attacking pawns so what white can do
here I mean Bishop's are usually better
than 99 games because they can support
and they can also defend but how do they
coordinate themselves here it's true and
I mean yeah the rook Bishop combination
is usually better than the rook knight
combination but in these sort of minor
piece with rook endings it's all about
optimizing both pieces and and and
trying to pressure the opponent's we
should point out that if I'm if I'm
doing my math correctly black is up upon
but it doesn't feel like blacks up upon
given these very ugly double h pawns
double isolated pawns on the H file
isolate pawn on f7 meanwhile White's
pawn structure also looks a bit ugly
isolated pawn on g2 on g3 but I really
like this pawn setup with c4 and d5 I
mean this this pawn is going to stay for
a while on d5 and it's going to give
white some some long-term push and maybe
maybe this is what's going to determine
the game if Alejandro can can optimize
the bishop in the rook but no white is
really facing an issue like what am I
gonna do rookie rookie to is so it's a
threat because then I'm attacking the
pawn and there's no route f2 because
Knight h3 fork that's a good point I
wreck up too and would be a pretty
tragic blunder I'm
during that if instead of whites going
for defense can you go for offense maybe
you play a move like rook f6 and go for
a pure counter play and if we imagine
that that rookie 2 is played perhaps
something like rook c6 and there's
already a threat on c8 and maybe you you
either give up the pawn or later you'll
play a bishop c3 and defend the pawn it
seems like still a very double-edged
position but you have to be I think a
little careful the way through f6 what
about the rule f6 I put Brooke II to
check and you cannot lie King f2 because
I have Luke b1 attacking the bishop and
threatening 94 sorry you want to play
rook e1 check after rookie 6 yes King
say King f2 and now I go Ruby 1 I'm
attacking the bishop and I'm threatening
fork bishops hanging 94 is coming that's
a good move enough to keep in mind that
at various points y can try and just
lunge forward with the pawn of course in
this position it's not going to work
that is a nice line though and if if
King G - you want to play rookie to
check most likely yes
oh this shows at 6 that's what happened
in the game by the way chose a different
move actually like Bishop f6 this is a
this is another resource we didn't
consider I was only looking at rook f6
but Bishop f6 put some pressure on the
Knights also controls the the d8 square
which if the pawn gets to d7 that would
be game over
so black does have to worry about the
always looming d6 push and meanwhile
maybe maybe rookie 2 rookies
- still playable or is it too risky to
go for or the question is if it's
necessary maybe I can play Knight e4 but
I don't want to get too
she 94 looks like a triple Fork it's not
a bad move I don't want to get too
exhausted by taking the pawns and then
allowing D 67 and then I'm in trouble
that's right black always has to be keep
an eye on the g5 fun and I mean
sometimes material is not as important
as the the tower of the past pawn and
black always has to keep this pawn at
bay
Robert August Arion is his time is
ticking and they have about 10 moves to
make time control we can see rookie -
what's played going for counter play and
always have to keep in mind sometimes
the rook cutting off the King on the
second-ranked combined with potential
Knight checks Knight f3 of course not a
move that's threatened but White has to
be a little bit concerned about the
safety of the King yes now the question
is what you do with white if I want to
push the pawn or defend the pawn on D -
yeah it's also play something like d3
mmm d3 just simply simply making sure
you have kind of a mini pawn chain you
don't really care about the pawn on you
- if rook take a - I assumed you would
just pushed e6 yes
so d3 could be an interesting resource
maybe that would trigger black to play a
move like rook deed rook d2 going after
the d3 pawn so it's not yeah it's really
not a clear position and I I have to
admit I wouldn't be comfortable playing
either side in time trouble that's
probably why I'm sitting here and the
players are sitting over there maybe you
have to Rudy - I can take the knight
play play rook f3 and try to play rook
e3 the thing is I really do not want to
connect the pawns so I would be very
very careful of doing this but maybe a
rookie 3 is the future because then I
can push my pawn these 67 that's right
but we have to keep in mind if if white
goes all out for this d6 push and it
doesn't work black has extra material
that could construct attempting to win
the hu pawn and you have to be careful
is white not
especially not to fix the kingside
pollen structure and not get your
desired t6 push yes and Alejandro
doesn't have too much time to calculate
if he can go for his Bishop things g5
Andrew get three Rudy three so probably
you will go with something that safe and
just for a moment I do want to go on to
the StuCo pin ballast game we kind of
dismissed it earlier
I've already dismissed this game twice
thinking that was gonna be a draw
thinking that light was just winning but
now we see we see an interesting example
of the coordination of the knight and
the rook and I'm curious here as black
going as black having some sort of
counter play with the mating attack
kingi three ideas looming oh this is
very interesting white now cannot take
the pawn on e5 because if white takes
Queen takes e5 I have Ruby three and
then the king will always run into the
fork with the Queen like King f1 rook f3
and you cannot play now kinky one
because of 93 so the King would have to
go back and then I go Ruby g3 again and
you cannot go can give two because of
Queen d3 there's a 93 right so the Queen
has to be careful of going too close to
the king where there can be some Forks
that's actually a beautiful perpetual
check you you basically just keep moving
your rook along wherever the king is
going and even if king h2 we keep we
keep checking the King and it doesn't
seem like white can escape this I would
be curious is there a way to like sack
the Queen and try and get the Queen side
pawns running if we look at the sign and
we also have to keep in mind that black
just wants to go King g3 and Ruby d1
checkmate
that's very true - yeah King g3 over t1
and white white soften up a ton of
material Queen and three pawns for rook
and Knight but sometimes King safety can
be more important than material I like
the way ballast is fighting back yes to
be it has to be somewhat admired here
that he has not given up and he's trying
to create as much fighting chances as
possible
so any other games to to look at as
we're kind of in the the heat of time
trouble and we also have a special guest
waiting we do have a special guest
should we should we take a quick break
and go to that we'll be back with
special guest right after this a moment
comes in chess when you need to test
yourself at a different level chess 24
premium offers the tools that you need
to reach your maximum potential from
hundreds of interactive video lessons to
becoming part of the chess 24 community
you can analyze with friends or coach
your students live you get twenty four
by seven coverage of chest news and
events access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenged them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a crucial situation in this game
Matheny must make a move but what will
it be all eyes are on the theme can make
a move a lot easier if you weren't doing
that right next to me it doesn't bother
me check the st. Louis Chess Club
celebrating 10 years of promoting
teaching and playing the game of chess
visit the st. Louis chess club and help
celebrate the 10th anniversary
hello everyone welcome back this is
women Grandmaster Catriona in Java and
I'm here with a special guest the
Scholastic Manager for the San Luis
chess club Carrie Intel honey everybody
so carrion can you introduce your work
within the Scholastic field I'd be happy
to sure would you like to look at you or
the camera camera you want the camera
sure
so the Scholastic team at the st. Louis
chess club runs a wide portfolio of
activities starting with first and
foremost our chess instruction in the
schools let's for example in our past
semester this spring semester we had
around close to 300 chess classes every
week each class running about 45 minutes
to an hour happening in over 90 schools
around the st. Louis area so that's our
that's our biggest focus is teaching
chess in the schools and we do that to a
wide range of schools we're very
fortunate that we have such a generous
founder and board that we can provide
and corporate partners nonprofit
partners that we can provide chess
instruction at no cost to many of the
city schools including our biggest
initiative with the st. Louis Public
School System oh wow so you talk about
so many schools how do you measure the
impact on community do you know in
numbers how many schools how many
children participate in these events
yeah so like for instance in our spring
semester it's about we're over 90
schools all around the city and the
average class size is really anywhere
from 8 to 12 students per class that's
what we've been finding that the classes
is so if you just do the math my math
isn't that great but it's you know at
least at least a thousand kids per
semester and in often cases it's more
because one school often will have more
than just the the one class happening
and at a time so in some schools they
get 5 10 even 15 hours a week of chess
at their school wow that's a great
promotion of chess I heard that there is
also a new Scholastic circuit circuit
what can you tell about sure so that's
one of our other big pieces of the
program is there are the Scholastic
tournaments that we
run we run one every month and I think
we're the only organization in st. Louis
to keep one going throughout the year
there are some other grading or
organizations out there doing good work
with tournaments but they they follow
the academic the school year closely so
they start and say October and in April
we run twenty you know twelve months a
year
and we but during the school years when
we run our Grand Prix so we have our own
version of the Grand Prix kind of cycle
and that finished with the April
tournament and we just had a banquet a
couple weeks ago at st. Louis University
who's our tournament partner that I
definitely have to say thank you to st.
Louis University and will Perkins
that's our partner there they make the
space available to us at no cost so we
can offer our tournaments to the kids at
a very very reasonable price this is so
wonderful to provide chestie so many
children I mean these schools in st.
Louis these children they must be so
happy to play chess what do you hear
from them yeah yeah we try to visit the
schools quite a bit we and whenever we
do we just see a lot of excited kids
they do love the game even if they don't
know all the moves right away but we get
them there slowly but surely so can it
be a little bit more off about who
supports these programs these
initiatives yeah and I definitely would
probably the give if you have a chance
to interview our development department
there they're the ones that really are
know the most about the funding and so
on but we definitely have some big
partners again first of all starting
with our founders and the board we have
corporate partners Monsanto Emerson
ascension these are some of the big
donors and again there are many more and
also the developed some of them want
wish to remain anonymous though and so
the development department knows better
which ones to talk about so I probably
should just stop there and let them
handle but we have just many many
supporters and so many individuals
well that give time and whatever
contributions they can and I know I'm
not thinking enough but there's not
really enough time to thank all the
people that come together for it's
incredible incredible initiative and
opportunity for children now what if
there are some viewers who wants to help
who want to help and support this
program what can they do
well definitely the first thing is to
just send us an email we have our own
email address for the Scholastic
Department scholastics at st. Louis
chess club org and if they send us an
email expressing their wish we can get
them involved right away they're
obviously also welcome to visit the club
if they're close by and ask for us that
way we'll be happy to come on over from
our office to the club and meet them and
talk to them so yeah many ways to get
involved perfect
so thank you so much for introducing us
to this scholastic work now is there
something else you would like to say it
maybe was not mentioned well there's
just so many mostly just you can you can
never say thank you enough for all the
great things that happen here but
definitely I just besides the we're so
fortunate that we have the chance to do
the Boy Scout merit badge workshops that
we do again with our tournament series
as well we have the community we have
outreach community where we bring chess
out into the city and the outdoors
especially in the summer chest pocket
parks we call them here in about the
city so there's just so many great
things that we're able to do because of
the fantastic you know support and
resources and community behind the
organization I always admire this
endless chess club how they work with
Super GM's like Magnus Carlsen inviting
them here but also caring about the
little children and people who cannot
afford maybe like private lessons and
try to make outreach so thank you so
much for all the work that you do
welcome thank you for having me thank
you so we will have a short break and
then we will get back because we've seen
some games are ending
in a nearby city you won't wanna skip
[Music]
[Music]
question on Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a trap here
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba 3 is an illegal move
here because white advances pawn to
square is not one but it still is
something we call autosome and you can
do that but you have to do it instantly
you can't wait for a move like let's say
play King in seven kimchi - and now try
because y'all played four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is a g5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we finally know who Lawrence
this is not how chest works certainly
would be much much more fun if Church to
work like this I don't think it does
well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chest tour st. Louis rapid and
blitz and Sinquefield Cup tournaments
will feature the world's best right here
in st. Louis st. Louis chess club is
celebrating its 10th anniversary and
these tournaments will be a highlight
you won't want to miss for tickets and
more information go to st. Louis chess
club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back this is
hummingbird master Katrina named Toa and
I am here with international master Eric
Rosen now we have a lot of games that
finished so let's see first maybe how
far played against Jeffrey John that's
right a lot of lolly games are done a
lot happened while we were while you
were doing the interview and I was gone
but here we're back vara Cobian has
defeated Jeffrey Zhang as we saw earlier
he had a clear end game advantage he was
able to increase his advantage further
the final position we see white is up
upon it still has a pasty pawn has this
outside pass H pawn and Jeffrey just
gave up in this position wow what a
great result for for VAR he starting
with two wins so he's off to a very good
start
that's right tough result for Jeffrey
and and tough result for me given that
Jeffrey was my pick for this tournament
but your your so far having a very good
pick with with our vara being the
predicted winner and we also can take a
look there is a decisive result in the
games to copy and against Bella's the
two utrgv teammates actually did not
make a draw that's right and we should
go back to the key moment we were
looking at this position earlier and we
were pretty impressed with the the
chances that black was creating going
for some kind of mating attack with the
rook with the knight the rook in the
King but sook open found just a very
simple resource that we didn't really
consider in this position just queen
take t3 sacrificing the Queen for the
rook and just just getting the pawns
rolling be 595 b6 and Knights are not
usually the happiest pieces defending
against multiple past pawns and we can
also see here how the double pawn is
really important because the knight
cannot cannot stop these two pawns
especially when there is this double
pawn so these three pawns are so strong
and there is nothing that's right just
to demonstrate if the pawn wasn't on b2
then black could potentially avoid or
blockade both pawns but here I would
think that b4 is just winning with the
simple thread of b5 c6
so night versus three pawns sometimes is
a close battle but in this case the
three
took him home yes and we also have
decisive result no decisive a draw
against Alejandro Ramirez and Robert
agus Ariana and Sergei McCain go against
Josh bruh del yeah that was a crazy game
it was very very dynamic opening very
creative play by Alejandro we can see
the current position if I'm counting
correctly Black is up three pawns why
why in the world with with a agus re and
take a draw being up three pawns let's
just go back to see how the draw
actually happened it was some some sort
of perpetual check I guess I guess
neither player wanted to play on givin
even though black is up three pawns I
mean white set up with a pawn on d5
Bishop on a six rook on e5 it's pretty
menacing and it seems like luck did not
want to risk it by capturing yet another
pawn because again it doesn't matter how
many pawns you have it matters about
sometimes the how far the strongest
passed pawn is pushed and perhaps
perhaps Robert was just worried about
the simple d6 where where white would be
close to a touchdown with 57 and d8 and
a white King doesn't have any other
chances because the King cannot go to f4
when we in the final position yeah the
final position if we look after to rook
g2 King III roof g3 so can get four
there is Luke every rakah three just
picking up the distance right yes or if
you after Luke g3 if you don't go king
f4 you would like to go King D - Darius
Knight f3 so what has to go for this for
this draw yeah that's interesting I
would be very very curious to see what
the engine says this is a type of game
where maybe you're not sure in the heat
of the moment whether one side is better
I'm sure both of the players will be
checking the engine alysus after the
game but we will know the again that
we're not using any and any engine
analysis and I mean I'm excited to check
this afterwards to see if either side
has a chance to play on so we should
look at the results so far we do have a
few games still pending let's go in and
take a look
the results from group a we have we
actually have four results that are done
firuzan the Cobian has been jeffrey
zhang in a very nice strategical battle
two out of two for for very Cobian we
also have the sift our Bailey defeating
Alexander in ditch not a not a bad start
for visi fan inversion yes
and Group B has also very interesting
situation now we see two games are still
pending but unrest opposed to copying
one and dinara has her first draw and
Alejandro I believe he has a second draw
right and Sergei and Josh have actually
drawn their games so that's true so we
have last game in Group B where Camille
dragon plays against at a Fabri home Ian
and we predicted that that will there
would be very hard to do something for
white to proceed in this position so we
will see yeah let's game and let's see I
mean any hope for for white to make
progress in this position and it's a
very it seems like a close battle White
has an extra pawn but we were looking
earlier we didn't see how how White's
gonna make further progress any idea is
how how I can proceed in this position
what he'll probably play something like
Bishop d3 my guess is that I can
exchange the bishops because there is
the past pawn so the corner game should
be winning so black will avoid it
playing something are you bishop do you
want but then I can try me me go King d4
I don't know how many trade
that's right I mean okay we can imagine
maybe the king especially with this last
move King III it's possible that whites
will actually use a pawn as a decoy on
h4 and try and just try and leave it
there and perhaps walk with the King d4
to c3 maybe somehow infiltrate on the
Queen side usually with these sort of
King pawn ending positions in this case
there are bishops on the board you
always want to be looking for entry
points you want to be looking at how you
can get your King into into blacks
territory in this case it doesn't appear
like there's any entry points on the
Kings side given the the wall that we
talked about earlier so it seems like
that this is White's only hope is to try
and try and somehow access a Foursquare
and try to get the King to b5 and if
light can get the King to c6 there would
be two things for black to worry about
obviously this this only.we pawn on c7
and of course still the the lingering
past H pawn which is always a big
annoyance for for for the black side so
switching gears just a little bit my my
co commentator has left and we are here
with firuzan the Cobian after very nice
win version how are you yeah I'm feeling
good yeah I think I played a pretty good
game I wasn't so sure if I had much out
of the opening but I thought I played
well you know in a late middle game sure
and I was very curious because you
played Geoffrey with the same color at
us championship what was the psychology
preparing for this game and choosing and
opening are you finding some sort of
deviation well this is my I don't know
fourth game already in group Phil which
Fe and he beat me in a last classic here
in a very interesting game he played
great and us championship I was pressing
but it was a draw and this is a
different line I chose to play
and we can go through this my good
friend Alex on Ashoke oh this place like
this and he played against Rey Robson
the US Championships so this Knight d7
is interesting there's a rook d8 here
main theory instead of that aside yeah
rook e8 and there were also some ideas
before he counselled if you go back a
little bit
mm-hm so another major theorist 96 sort
of b1 ideas and a6
look c1 sorry slow down after night
everyone rook t1 yeah and if black plays
a6 you go back to Luke c1 interesting so
anyway this is just a lots of lots of
theory here and I'm sure you were
looking at these lines like yeah I was
looking at this but it's still very hard
to find advantage against Green fold so
so let's go back to the game so he
played castle and 97 d5 and I actually
had this game before
and last year world blitz championship
begins yonder bomb Miyaichi
and I played c4 here in that game as
well
took 92-86 b6 yen he wants to play
Knight g4 and I played h3 against a
nipple and it was pretty equal position
but then I analyzed this f3 King f2 idea
I'm not sure if it gives might much
advantage but I thought at least he
wouldn't be familiar with and I put a
kink on f2 but I think he reacted very
well this 97 was very good and now he
wants to play f5f5f5 in fact dropping my
bishop so I couldn't see anything better
than just playing f4 because I don't see
how to deal with this f5 move so were
you rather preparation yeah 97 97 was
very strong by Geoffrey here and - ok
it's very sharp here and so at what
point did you feel like the game was
swaying in your favor um well this is
still complicated and I took a lot of
time here because Bishop hdn I didn't
see much after GTX f5
I thought this was the way to play for
him
maybe we if you go back just a move
Geoffrey we briefly analyzed after the
game Geoffrey mentioned the move instead
of Knight f6 he takes f4 which i think
is probably good enough for equality for
black Bishop takes f4 then I have to
play ESP Knight e5 and black is very
very active here so I think I have to
take the knight Bishop takes e5 Bishop
takes e5 and we'll say this does seem a
lot more pleasant for Allah keeping the
initiative yes this is about deacon I
think I go Bishop d3 and so this was
probably more balanced way to play but
he played Knight f6 which was very
interesting I took like something like
15 minutes here because so many lines
here if let's say I try to be greedy I
think I might be in big trouble if I
take on g6 it's very interesting Waianae
g4 check King g2 Knight X III King takes
III I so sorry GT x h7 intermediate
share sir and now very important not to
take the spawn because I will get a very
important MP later on with the Bishop d3
check so it plays King h8 here King III
and now he takes on a4 and I have to
take back in Bishop h6 and I think my
position is it's very ugly onion the the
pawn count isn't irrelevant and blacks
pieces are just solo players locative
here I might be in big big trouble here
so of course I didn't go for this but
just as an interesting position I line
you know I'm up three pawns but probably
other than that I'm sure that's why you
spend so much time I'm delving into okay
the main concern was Bishop a5 I didn't
consider that much because positionally
I thought I will be maybe very slightly
better because if you get to exchange
the light square bishop in this in this
line in general it's a big
accomplishment for white just in general
so I was very happy so the key line I
think we should look at is g TX f5
instead of Bishop f5 now I have to take
on e5 Knight g4 Bishop g4 takes have to
play King g2 a very important move
Bishop takes e5 and if I allow him to
play Bishop f5 I might even be very
slightly worse because of the tradition
but I think I have a very important
movie emission to h6 mm-hmm
and this creates some problems because
now if let's say rook e8 I have rook H F
1 and it's very strong because the
bishop is not coming to the 5 that's
nice I mean the initiative is very
important and restrict plan exactly
Bishop on h6 is very very powerful and
if he goes instead of rook e8 Bishop g7
maybe that's the best line Bishop takes
King takes and I think maybe very
slightly better for white the probably
black should be okay after Bishop f5
here so this is what I was kind of
expecting but I was very happy after
Bishop he took Bishop takes f5 so I took
Juke h3 stopped 94 finally because I had
to deal with this magic for the entire
game so I was happy at least to play
this and my my main I went up when I was
thinking I was thinking you should play
e4 here actually instead of okay
a8 I think maybe I'm slightly better but
I'm not sure if or I have to play for
now 98 so Knight has to go to d6 so much
better square for the knight for sure if
I go ideas so I play Roxy to 96 and okay
a 5 I have some Ruby 1 ideas I think I
have maybe a little bit of pressure but
the knight on d6 is very well placed the
bishop on g7 is strong so I think this
position is probably roughly equal
because I can never use the a 1 or B 2
squares the bishop is very powerful so I
think this is about eco that's true so
going forward with the rest of the game
at what point to you well I think if we
go back sure I think this is the
critical moment was here Luque aid is
already slightly dubious and after I
took I think 94 is just blundered
because Geoffrey missed
simply that after I take take King be
too it's very powerful king will always
block it upon and
think this is already much worse for him
and another important detail here it
looks very natural to play look hf1
but if I play this move hf1
if I play it looks very natural right
Bishop g3 you can play and now if I play
rook g1
he has rook f3 but I cannot do anything
about it and same thing happens if I
exchange the rooks and I play rook g1
okay faith rook takes a fate so work
after it G 1 2 K 3 still and he's up a
pawn so that's why I had to start out
with Luke CF CF 1 which looks a bit
unnatural but you have to be aware of
there's a very important detail there if
we go back if now he takes on g3 is a
blunder I play rook hg 1 look F 1 very
important in between rook g3 check very
nice and then I can take the run and you
hear this important detail because
otherwise he will be able to get a rook
on f3 if I do that's true I think I got
one and then but that's initiative with
chatting my whole idea was yeah to
prevent him from entering on the F file
yeah then I think I play too I think I
played correctly the rest of the game so
Bishop f4 is important Bishop 25 is very
powerful and I can never push my D pawn
so that's why I want to exchange the
bishops if he goes Bishop d4 it looks
kind of not sure but I think up to
Bishop c7 I'm just winning then I just
start pushing the D pawn yeah the the
lingering G pawn is the major block is
he can never go to Bishop and gaminess
and he can never enter a bishop and game
because he will be losing because of the
D pawn that's right the a7 palm being on
the dark square and this was a very big
team throughout the the round to that if
you were watching some of the other
games but we had a lot of games with
bishops of the same color with with
pawns being fixed on on bad squares and
long-term potential weaknesses so you
can't go forward the next few moves I
think so no he played III yeah this e3
move looked a bit peculiar I wasn't so
sure probably it's not the best move but
on the other hand I think yeah I think
it's probably not that good D tree but
maybe black has some other ideas but it
was very difficult to find a move
actually because
my last move a four was quite important
to prevent all kinds of Concha play
involving b5 because black wants to play
b5 tossed upon and then we take on d5 so
that prevents us so now I think we will
enter just a winning game game Bishop e3
he takes takes Bishop e3 King III and
then I took I had about 15 minutes here
I probably I spent like 12 minutes here
but at least I found I think I find the
right plan because I have so many
options I was they need to play rook f6
and put the rook on c6 but I couldn't
see a clear way to win enough so that's
why I spent my time and I said okay I'm
gonna play we should rook f3 because now
I'm plating Bishop f4 and the reason he
played rookie 7 it looks very natural to
play King g7 here but the problem he
runs into Bishop f4 and he doesn't have
rook afraid any idea any longer because
of Bishop h6 check that's nice tattooing
it's actually very important because
once I eliminate the bishop I knew that
rookin game is just lost because D Phi
upon is very strong and it was just so
weak and so many yes I'm basically
playing up a pawn here technically so he
played rookie 7 no no he played yeah if
he plays rook f7 there was another
alternative I just play King he for
rookie 7 can get 5 rock g4 sorry rook F
7 kg for Rupert e7 and then I play
Bishop g5 here very nice complete
domination then there's no counter play
and I will just I think I was just
planning to play rook III and rookie
stuff and just trade the rooks
absolutely and a win again game I have
to admire your endgame technique we
played once such ACOG open few years ago
and you got like a very small advantage
and you're you play very nicely to come
and build up small advantages so it
seems like you you play well yeah
yeah I mean I think I played correctly
the rest of the game so we can just
quickly there a couple of little details
rook e1 so I take so I repeated the
position because I was in time travels
and time but then I think the final
detail was he's just not in time to take
the upon defy polishes to a quick kinga
for now I want to play King at 5 and
king f7 the final final
we have five very important because I
want little cage seven and that prevents
King be seven because of rookie
forecheck and if it is rook f1 I just
simply go King be five king these six
very nice yeah very instructive game I'm
sure to show us some of your students
yes yeah sure this game to my students
you know finally happy to play a good
game against group of because it was
very difficult opening to get anything
and somehow managed today to get
something that I feel comfortable with
that's right and you can't ask for a
much better start to win so far yes know
who you fight tomorrow I'm not sure
actually know okay I don't know if
they're actually well we'll get to that
very soon yeah how do you feel going
forward through the rest of the
tournament
I feel good it's a good start decide
also good started the US Championship
started with two out of two but somehow
midpoint I ran out of energy and just
started to play badly it's time hope I
hope to play better absolutely have a
better better sure you know but better
finish and mid midpoint of determinately
very happy with the start because I need
a good tournament after the
disappointing US Championships exactly
well we won't keep you any longer ago go
get some rest and good luck for the rest
of the tournament take it so moving on
we have we still have the dragon dragon
Abraham Ian game underway the position
hasn't changed much let's go back and
and see what happened over the last few
moves we can see they reach time control
with Camille having just under half hour
Tata has just under 20 minutes we could
expect this game to go on for much
longer I will reiterate what I was
talking about earlier with White's
main plan being to walk the King around
to to a four and and somehow invade with
with eventual king c6 but sometimes
planned this like this it's easier said
than done let's go back and see what
White has been up to a lot of dancing
around and that's what we'll see in some
times these is kind of long grinding
positions is you just
you want to make a bunch of moves trying
and get some time from the increment and
and try and put your opponent on your
pressure try and get some some
consistently new positions where your
appointment has to think and even if
Camille dragon isn't objectively winning
I think one of the main strategies is
trying etat of into time trouble again
given that they're already in sudden
death a sudden death fine control and
somehow provoke a blunder
let's just go forward I'm not going to
give too much commentary on these moves
this seems like some dancing around I
mean why does always maybe debating
whether or not to play Bishop d3 but
this is a current position after Bishop
e1 and I have a feeling that white might
be hesitant to play King c3 which would
allow kinda the very annoying king e5
and we have to keep in mind that bucks
blacks King can't get into the game or
white doesn't want black scheme to get
in thinking too early so we're gonna
keep an eye on this but we should go to
the the current standings in group group
a where we have a number of games going
on and I would like to welcome back
Catarina them so of a Catarina what you
see so far so we see that var actually
and Vasa they are the only one here
leading with two out of two excellent
start
unfortunately Alexandra Indyk has zero
out of two but you know this is a very
long tournament you can start with two
zeros and then win the tournament I know
this happened during for example Moscow
open there was a player who started with
two zeros and won the tournament so two
games doesn't mean anything in such a
long tournament
that's very true it's all about kind of
regrouping taking it one game at a time
but with that let's go on to pairings
for tomorrow for for group a I'm
expecting a lot of a lot of exciting
matchups so we have Sam Savion against
Benjamin book Daniel Freedman against
the Irish Arabic Alexandre in ditch
Peter Prohaska Jeffrey Zhong against
Vasa through our body it's gonna be very
interesting match and Rina German bias
against vara Cobian
and we will have to keep our eyes on
both perceived our Bailey
provisional Cobian who are off to very
quick starts with with two out of two
and they are both playing black tomorrow
against strong players so we'll see how
how those games go let's go on to the
current standings in Group B where a lot
of games are finished we currently only
have one game pending that game that we
were just looking at between Camille
dragon and Tata Abraham Ian we can see
in this group that there are no perfect
scores but if Camille wins this game he
will be the only two out of two in Group
E so what is the pairings for tomorrow
let's see so we have tactical Brahimi
and against inarizaka Zola so the two
female players are gonna fight it off
tomorrow then we have Josh Friedel
against camel dragoon Robert Alcazar yon
against Sergei might think of mud
bellows against Alejandro Ramirez and JJ
Ally Morandi against Andres to coffin
what is your key match what do you think
Eric I'm excited to see the ladies play
I mean I know they're they're both very
fighting players and if Tata can hold on
and draw this game I'm sure she'll be
very relieved and hopefully have some
momentum going forward into tomorrow but
we're going to leave this game going and
end it here so if you guys want to
follow the games you can replay all of
the games on us chess champs calm we
will be back here at 3:30 central time
tomorrow the games start at 1 p.m.
central time and I look forward to
another exciting day of chess yes see
you tomorrow bye bye guys
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you